Hi zusammen! Heute machen wir ein stark angefragtes Rezept, was es noch gar nicht auf meinem Kanal gibt:
Quarkbällchen wie vom Bäcker!
Und das ist auch wieder so ein Rezept:
Kuscheligen Pullover an, Haare zusammenbinden und einfach nur drauf los frittieren!
(Hamza: *lacht*)
Der Teig ist sehr, sehr einfach also ich schreibe euch auch wie immer alle ganze genauen Mengenangaben unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Wir starten natürlich mit Quark.
Ich nehme heute Magerquark. Es funktioniert aber auch mit z.B. 20%igem Quark, habe ich ja auch schon ausprobiert.
Das kommt jetzt alles in eine Schüssel und dafür nehmt ihr euch auch gleich zum Verrühren einfach nur einen Schneebesen.
So, Quark..ich schab gleich die Reste aus.
(Hamza: Jaja, ist klar!)
Mache ich immer wenn die Kamera aus ist!
(Hamza: Jaja!)
So, Eier mit rein, Zucker und Vanilleextrakt
und danach haben wir nur..Achso, Prise Salz! Denn Hamza..?
Prise Salz?
(Hamza: Ich hab's vergessen!)
(Hamza: Hebt den..süßen Geschmack!)
Hebt den süßen Geschmack!
So! Und dann verrühre ich das kurz
und danach kommen unsere 2 trockenen Zutaten hinein und das ist einmal Mehl und Backpulver.
(Hamza: Du überraschst mich immer wieder so in den Videos, auf einmal muss ich irgendwas sagen!)
Ja das ist wie in der Schule, ne? Auf einmal nimmt der Lehrer dich dran!
(Hamza: *lacht* Ja ich achte nur auf das Video und dann muss ich plötzlich reden!)
(Hamza: Ja, da schabt sie den letzten Rest aus, ne?)
Ja klar!
Ihr könnt das auch vorab miteinander verrühren.
Wie lange hat das gedauert - 60 Sekunden?
(Hamza: Ey Leute der Teig ist schon fertig!)
Krank oder?
(Hamza: Wie geht das?!)
Hamza ist schockiert, er dachte wir drehen jetzt erstmal 3 Stunden!
(Hamza: Ich schwör's dir! Ich mach ab jetzt selber Quarkbällchen, sind auch voll lecker!)
Ey Leute ich sag's euch:  also wirklich immer selber machen! Also klar kann man die ja auch mal draußen holen
aber das geht einfach so schnell und man hat so viele! Man hat so, so viele!
(Hamza: Quarkbällchen sind ja auch gesund, ne? Ist ja auch Eiweiß! *lacht*)
Das sei mal so dahingestellt Hamza ob das so gesund ist!
So, jetzt geht's an Frittieren! Schnappt euch Frittierfett und einen tiefen Topf.
Und ich hab das jetzt nicht soo voll gemacht. Also das reicht mir hier schon, das sind ca. 500ml.
Wenn ihr einen Schaschlikspieß reinhaltet und die Bläschen -
Also das ist schon fast ein bisschen zu schnell, wie sie aufsteigen.
(Hamza: Ach die müssen aufsteigen, dann ist es warm oder heiß genug, ne?)
Genau, dann ist das heiß genug.
Also wie gesagt: Das war mir gerade fast schon ein bisschen zu schnell wie die Bläschen aufsteigen, also zu heiß.
Deswegen immer wieder die Hitze runternehmen und wenn ihr merkt: "Okay, es ist nicht heiß genug"
die Hitze wieder hochschrauben sage ich mal.
Und dann werdet ihr auch ein Gefühl dafür kriegen. Also ihr kriegt auf jeden Fall nach dem zweiten oder dritten ein Gefühl dafür.
Und jetzt schnappt ihr euch 2 Esslöffel, macht den nicht ganz so voll und verschiebt den quasi immer.
Und irgendwann, also nach 3-4 Mal verschieben habt ihr so einen Ball.
Das könnt ihr auch mit einem Eisportionierer machen aber ich hab darauf heute mal verzichtet
einfach damit ich euch zeigen kann, wie's funktioniert wenn ihr keinen da habt.
So und jetzt einfach da reinfallen lassen.
(Hamza: Wie lange?)
1-2 Minuten also nicht lange!
So, das war jetzt grad mal so ein bisschen mehr als 1min. Ein bisschen abtropfen lassen und direkt in Zucker wälzen.
Und fertig sind meine Quarkbällchen!
Ich muss ehrlich zugeben: Das Schwierigste an dem Rezept ist einfach rauszufinden, wie lange eure Quarkbällchen jetzt bei euch brauchen.
Und es ist so, dass wenn das Öl nicht heiß genug ist, saugen sich die Quarkbällchen mit Fett voll, dann kann man sie nicht gebrauchen.
Wenn es zu heiß ist, wird's außen schnell dunkel und bleibt innen roh.
Daher kann's auch mal sein, dass ihr wirklich den ersten, zweiten, dritten einfach mal als Testkaninchen braucht.
Und ihr könnt auch zwischendurch immer mal aufschneiden und gucken, ob's durch ist.
Das ist auch super, super wichtig zwischendurch mal Proben zu machen und dann kann euch wirklich nichts mehr schief gehen!
Ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Wir gönnen uns das jetzt - oh erstmal immer diese ganzen Fotos und so, Outro..
Ich muss mich immer richtig gedulden Leute! Aber danach gönne ich mir meine Quarkbällchen.
Euch ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen und bis zum nächsten Mal! Hinterlasst ein Abo damit ihr nichts mehr verpasst
und dann freue ich mich, wenn ihr bei meinem nächsten Video wieder einschaltet. Tschüss, eure Kiki!